award-winning mystery writer and
children's author James Patterson has
sold hundreds of millions of books
worldwide also holds again his world
record for the most number one New York
Times bestsellers his newest project was
revealed yesterday Patterson will work
with former President Bill Clinton on a
novel that gives readers an inside look
at what it's like to be President his
current co-author is his son Jack the
two teamed up to write the book penguins
of America the children's book
illustrates a humorous connection
between penguins and humans James and
Jack Patterson join us now at the table
good morning good morning how do you
have a loving family yeah so how does
this work I mean you do you call you say
dad I want to talk about a book about
penguins or does he know you like
penguins and so therefore how does it
work I don't know how well it started
out way back when when Jack was little
now he's big yeah I guess he liked the
Morgan Freeman narrated films he would
he would always draw this connection
between penguins and humans the march of
the PL so for example oh yeah yeah we
want to do penguins on on your show we
do each one of you in your penguin would
have the jewelry early wheeling and or
whatever that would be you know we get
parody yeah yeah
breakfast hour on television for five
that he liked penguins and then years
later you said okay we could do
something together yeah and we just
started talking I'm sorry go ahead
no no way I mean like we kind of just
took the idea and ran with it you know I
guess you know we consider the idea of
like doing it with like bleeding sheeps
and stuff and you know different
anthropomorphic options and I think we
have you done sau-lan penguins more than
600 of these books with partners 6,500
yeah no no I thought I read something
was amazing well you waiting don't
believe the fake news you know but what
fascinated you jack is a connection
between penguins and people because
number one can I just say the
illustrations on the book are amazing
names yeah and I took I when I was
reading and I said I'll bet jack came up
with this one I'll bet you came of that
for instance that came up with that one
that Starbucks a what's an option on
that one like jumbo skinny chocolate
nonfat chocolate Cod one was gentleman
for for penguins I said I know that you
did
I never Marilyn Marilyn Marilyn yo
parody yeah the Penguins at the urinal
hey buddies keep your eyes on your own
flipper yeah both kind of did that yeah
a new one mm-hmm who's the audience for
this book uh you know to to 102 I mean
kids are going to like it they won't get
some of them but they'll get a lot of it
but that's what kids are you know they
don't they're used to not getting
everything but they'll love the
illustrations and then adults it also
tell us about this Clinton deal that
you've got him well the title of the
book is the president is missing and
President Clinton and I will have more
to say when the president is found ah
who's a better collaborator jack or the
president they both know about good this
is my you know Picasso had his has a new
serie this is my my bill period but I'm
going to do mr. bill I'm going to do I'm
going to read uh tree do Billy Budd and
maybe bill Shakespeare instead I read
that you want to do something with the
President and include details that only
a president would know yes and I think
that that's a very close yeah no no it's
very very cool it's very cool it's a
wonderful and sofa we're about halfway
through it and it's it's very exciting
and and I'm learning so much
I don't do this you're right with a
collaborator like that with presently
you sit at a table very carefully yes no
I mean we've been together a few times
and we we have we don't live that far
apart when when I'm up here but we've
met in floor than we've met in
Westchester and we talk on the phone a
lot is there going to be more than one
book with President Clinton maybe well I
want to go back to penguin penguin up
sitting here President Clinton or
penguin would be I suppose I would work
but I think president's missing with his
penguin sort of the thinking is that you
wanted to eliminate what you call Summer
Slide that in the summertime when kids
are out of school you know they sort of
slack off with books can you relate to
that well I mean I guess as a kid I
definitely felt like that like you know
probably happened with me and even you
know as a high schooler you know you'd
get out of school and you kind of like
sit on the couch and whatever and do
whatever you did in the summer and then
I remember returning to school and kind
of being like whoa my handwriting got
worse that's
yeah Wow okay I mean kids slide I'm they
have statistics on this if they slide
for six straight years my time here in
sixth grade they they've lost two grades
in the summers on the parents it's on
the parents parents who've got to get
books for the kids go to the library go
online go into your favorite bookstore
you know what it's the consequences of
your desire to to look at small towns
across America I don't think enough
attention is paid sometimes it took two
people grow up in you know that's the
popularity of hillbilly ology you know I
think that's what part of what that is
it's hard to get out of small towns I
mean you know yes for uh you don't get
out right I grew up in Newburgh New York
and a lot of very bright people they
kind of still not that it's a bad thing
to be in Newburgh but it's it's hard
it's hard to get out of there Jack did
you love reading as much as your dad did
was he a big reader to you was he a big
reader to me yeah did he read to me yeah
no nobody threw them at me no I don't
know no I mean I think as a young kid I
was kind of like a typical kid I didn't
really particularly enjoy books but I
think I've definitely when Jack was
developed an affinity for them now when
he was a we said sue and I said Jack
you're going to read every day this
summer we to stop the Summer Slide and
his initial thing was do I have to he
said yes you wanna live in the garage
but by the end of the summer and to
think the key thing is we went out and
got cool books he was going to like
everything from Percy Jackson to wrinkle
and time and he read a dozen books and
then you know when Jack Dukas SATs you
got 800 and rain reading so it paid off
in a big way for him and now he's at
Brown University wrinkle in time is
going to be a movie next year directed
by Ava Duvernay you must go oh really
I just yes we work with her Ava yes
she's awesome and I just reread it last
month did you yes I want to read it
again but worth going back this out huh
the twins you're gonna stop this summer
yes which means it can I have two hymns
yeah don't worry
there's twins in a wrinkle in time as
well yeah thanks Jamie Jack Patterson
congratulation you about perfect to see
both of you